drones have become an essential tool in
modern agriculture revolutionizing the
way Farmers monitor crops and manage
Fields today we'll show you the best
agricultural drones for farming in 2024
and how they're transforming the future
of Agriculture whether you're a
smallscale farmer are managing hundreds
of Acres drones are making it easier
than ever to monitor crop Health map
fields and apply Resources with
Precision stay tuned as we explore the
top drones for farming that can take
your operation to the next level in
2024 overview of drone technology in
agriculture drone technology is rapidly
transforming agriculture offering
Farmers a powerful tool to manage their
crops with Precision unlike traditional
methods which often rely on visual
inspections or manual labor drones
provide a bird's eye view of vast Fields
allowing for quick and accurate data
collection whether it's monitoring crop
Health checking irrigation systems or
identifying pest infestations drones can
do it all in a fraction of the time
equipped with high resolution cameras
and advanced sensors these drones can
capture detailed images and data that
help farmers make informed decisions in
real time the ability to analyze crop
Health from above also allows for
targeted interventions meaning farmers
can apply water fertilizers or
pesticides only where they are needed
reducing waste and optimizing resources
as drone technology and agriculture
continues to advance the benefits are
are clear more efficiency reduced costs
and better yields this is why drones are
becoming an indispensable tool on Modern
Farms best farming drones for small and
medium Farms when it comes to small and
medium-sized Farms having the right
drone can make all the difference for
these operations two models stand out
for
2024 the DJI agris T30 is perfect for
precision spraying offering a 30 L tank
that allows it to cover large areas with
fertilizers or pesticides efficiently
this drone is equipped with Advanced
Spraying Systems that Target specific
areas reducing waste and ensuring the
even distribution of chemicals for crop
mapping and health monitoring the parot
Bluegrass Fields is an excellent choice
this drone offers high- performance
multispectral sensors that monitor plant
Health providing real-time data on crop
conditions the parrot Bluegrass is also
budget friendly making it ideal for
farmers who want to integrate drone
technology without a hefty price tag
both of these drones offer a great
balance of performance affordability and
ease of use for small and medium Farms
looking to optimize their operations top
drones for large scale farming for large
scale Farms that need to cover vast
areas efficiently high performance
drones are a must the sense fly ebx is
one of the best options for large farms
in
2024 this drone can cover up to 1,200
acres in a single single flight
providing detailed maps that help
farmers track crop growth soil
conditions and water distribution it's
long flight time and robust build make
it ideal for mapping large Fields
quickly and accurately another top
Contender for large scale operations is
the DJI Phantom 4
rtk this drone offers real-time
kinematic rtk positioning which ensures
centimeter level accuracy when creating
field maps it's perfect for precision
agriculture allowing Farmers to monitor
Fields with unparalleled accuracy these
drones not only save time but also allow
for better decision making by providing
detailed data that manual inspection
simply can't offer drones for crop
monitoring and health analysis when it
comes to crop monitoring drones accuracy
and real-time insights are essential for
Farmers the matrice 300 rtk stands out
as one of the best drones for detailed
crop Health analysis in
2024 with its multi-sensor capabilities
it can detect nutrient deficiencies Pest
infestations and even water stress
across your Fields this drone's Advanced
sensors allow Farmers to spot issues
before they become significant problems
giving them time to act quickly another
great option is the centa 6X which
offers highresolution multi-spectral
Imaging this drone can detect crop
health issues that are invisible to the
naked eye such as subtle changes in
plant Vigor or water stress allowing
Farmers to make early informed
interventions by using these crop
monitoring drones farmers can maximize
yields minimize losses and ensure that
their crops remain healthy throughout
the growing season with so many powerful
drones available we'd love to hear from
you what features are most important for
your farm are you more interested in
drones for crop monitoring or do you
need something for precision spraying
drop a comment below and let us know
what type of drone you think would make
the biggest difference on your farm
thanks for watching in our next video
we'll explore how AI is being integrated
into drone technology to push farming
automation even further make sure to
subscribe and hit the Bell icon so you
don't miss any of our future updates on
the latest farming Tech